we're doing a draft now best comeback
stories of 2018 other than what i just
used on him oh my god
he's out there and he throws haymakers
below the belt he just throws hay makers
below the belt go ahead okay give me a
tails chris then you better pick tails
and not going with this jerk today
holy cow
tails
what a shock i know i already know what
it's going to be
this is setting up oh aaron rodgers
it's gonna be a great comeback year how
can i not pick aaron rodgers first of
all
i do think the green bay packers are a
better football team it does sound like
the offense can change to a degree jimmy
graham's part of the equation now i
think that that makes things better for
aaron rodgers i think the defense is
going to be better as well so the
supporting cast around him i know minus
jordy nelson okay but i don't think
that's a huge blow to this football team
i just know that between him being
healthy the way he looked on that first
drive at the steelers game the way he's
been calling out guys on his team and
kind of been no nonsense for the first
time uh as the quarterback for the green
bay packers to me just goes oh watch out
nfl here he comes mr mvp himself yes i
just think aaron rodgers and the green
bay packers are back in the fold because
of him and their super bowl team because
he's at quarterback you know you had
been losing the toss recently and it was
due that you would win it but i'll tell
you what you really got the benefit
today i should get next two there's lots
of good ones but you want to take the
next table no no no i'm not going to
keep crying
that's right you're tired forget it you
were ready you were ready to give it to
me i'm a nice guy let me go with otto
beckham jr just because i know that's
the one that you were just hoping that i
passed on but think about it yes he's
healthy he's about to get paid at some
point between now and the first sunday
the regular season when the giants
welcome tom coughlin back to town as the
jaguars return to new jersey for their
game against beckham and company he's
going to get paid and i think he's going
to just let it all hang out you take
that injury risk off of him you shift it
to the team you got saquon barkley who's
going to be attracting all of the
attention it's going to open up the
passing game eli manning has a chip on
his shoulder wants to prove them wrong
last year for benching him for a week
for geno smith i think it's all setting
up for odell beckham jr to have a
monstrous year and
we're we're going to be like wow we
forgot how much fun football was when
otto beckham jr was a part of it yeah i
mean there's no denying that i mean we
had some big-time stars missed football
last year and i think your point about
the help around obj is really the thing
right i mean he's going to have a system
he's not going to line up in the same
place all game long and there's going to
be other weapons to worry about and a
run game for the first time really at
odell beckham jr's career to where i'm
with you i mean i think he's going to go
off all right number two pick i'm
standing at quarterback what did we say
da shawn watson and i think that's what
i'm going to say when i talk about see i
thought you were just adjusting the
aaron rodgers songs rogers gets high
pitched desean watson gets low pitch
okay but i got to go with deshaun watson
i mean just from what we saw last year
and that glimpse uh before he got hurt
and tore his acl in practice which it
sounds like he did it in the seahawks
game he was as good as any quarterback
in football i mean he was up there in
the conversation with aaron rodgers some
of the things he did in that new england
game the seattle seahawks game oh if
you're watching on tv the 50-yard
touchdown that helped them beat the
bengals in his first start ever he's a
special athlete but what i think took
him over the edge for me is he's special
in the pocket and he's a special thrower
and decision maker and that's where i
just go watch out nfl don't be shocked
that this guy's the the best quarterback
or best player in this sport two or
three years from now yeah i can't deny
that either there were concerns about
his interceptions yeah from clemson and
what happened was at the nfl level the
window got smaller and he got more
active right right and he found a level
of performance i'm not i shouldn't be
making your it's okay
i was nice
just think all right uh
let me uh let me go with uh oh a guy
that this is the ultimate proof of how
in the nfl once you're injured and
you're gone for the year it's out of
sight out of mind david johnson the
cardinals running back sorry damn
i mean the guy they were talking
legitimately this wasn't pie in the sky
adrian peterson rushing for 2500 yards
this was real a thousand yards rushing a
thousand yards receiving for david
johnson in 2017. the guy was phenomenal
his first two years in the nfl and what
a great guy
nice guy
very humble very centered and grounded
and he gets it and he had that horrible
wrist injury against the lions week one
of last year and it's just like we
forgot about it yeah i know it's like oh
he was the number one consensus pick in
every fantasy draft last year he gets
injured week one it's like david johnson
who's that well he's going to
reintroduce himself to the nfl this year
regardless of who's playing quarterback
regardless of who the number two
receiver is regardless of what they have
on defense david johnson is going to
make us remember who david johnson was
yeah i i can't i mean that was who i
wanted to go with next i almost thought
about taking him in the second round i
mean yeah this is a guy that's oh you
know over 2 000 yards all-purpose type
of player uh i think he's the younger
slightly better version of le'veon bell
if you want to say i i do i think he's
younger and more explosive so if you
gave me a choice between david johnson
and le'veon bell i know i'm making your
case i'd take david johnson that's how
awesome he is and you're right it's
unreal how much he was just forgotten
about last year one of the best players
in the league so that's not a bad pick
for you um all right just coming down
the two guys
yeah it is tough because there's a few
good guys on this list still
all right i gotta go with j.j watt i'm
gonna go with jj uh j.j watt i think in
that houston texas defense gedavion
county being the force he is whitney
merciless being back again this year uh
after injury as well romeo cornell
taking over the reigns of the defense
once again and everything i've seen from
j.j watt and heard is that it looks as
explosive and as good as ever so i don't
think he's going to leave the nfl and
sacks but man will he be disruptive and
i think he's going to be in that
conversation for one of the most
disruptive defensive players in the game
because of the help around him you got
to be a little concerned about double
teaming because they have a lot of other
good players on that front seven i think
watts uh certainly you got to watch out
for it i'm just concerned about his
ability to stay healthy it all started
after his fifth year the back issues and
you're going to get double and triple
teamed and that back's already impaired
you know we forgot about it last year
because it was that that that weird
tibial plateau fracture right but the
back i think is something that is still
potentially a concern at any given
moment in any given game he is a big guy
who plays with physicality and he faces
a lot of stress that's going to go right
down to the bottom of that back so that
would be my concern with what
i'm going to because we can do players
or teams
i'm going to broaden my focus here and
this really isn't a comeback but
everyone thinks it is because the
seattle seahawks were nine and seven
last year they were not horrible right
they didn't make it to the playoffs for
the first time since 2012 right and it
provided the occasion for pete carroll
the head coach whether it was his
decision or someone else's to gut the
coaching staff
to make some significant changes on a
roster that was top-heavy with bloated
veteran contracts and to refocus around
the guy that you put as essentially 1b
to aaron oh aaron rodgers 1a yes russell
wilson as the second best quarterback in
football they're building the team
around him he's the center of the
universe and that's how you do it with a
franchise quarterback
you build around him and i think this
team can be very good this year they're
excited about rashad penny they are
excited about what they can do
defensively with the young guys that
step up cam chancellor was a sixth
rounder richard sherman was a fifth
rounder we didn't know who they are
until they became who they were and with
some of these younger guys we're going
to feel the same way i think the
seahawks are going to be an unexpected
force not by me yeah but i think they're
going to turn it around this year and
people are going to be like wow why did
we why did we write off this team with
what russell wilson could that would
have been i mean that would have been a
good pick in the unexpected forced draft
but this is the comeback draft you sound
really a comeback but everybody thinks
it's
not really a comeback coming back to the
playoffs okay fine
you heard that stats are we going
another round yeah
next round
you want an extra round go ahead okay
um spoken to a guy who guy who still has
one ready to go i'm gonna i do i you got
a few i can help you out if you need i'm
going to ezekiel elliott okay
it's not really a comeback
because it is a comeback after all the
crap he had to deal with last year i
mean a six-game suspension and weekly
trips to the principal's office whether
it was roger goodell or jerry jones or
whatever it may be i think ezekiel
elliott is going to be back as the
leading rusher in the nfl this season
behind that offensive line i just think
he's a man possessed he hasn't played he
looks phenomenal
as far as
a little that pudginess that we talked
about early in the year last year i
think because he couldn't train and
focus on football because he always had
to do something to deal with these off
the field issues i think he comes back
and reminds everybody that he's one of
the best backs in the league and always
i'm always a little skittish about the
whole pudginess thing but when you walk
around with your shirt halfway up and
you announce to the world
i mean he clearly didn't have one he got
mad at us because we called it out
during the season but then after the
season he admitted he wasn't in as good
a shape as he would like to be i don't
know how he's going to do behind that
offensive line if they don't get those
issues straightened out that's the
martin should be okay i think well you
got zach martin you've got travis travis
with guillen bar a syndrome you've got
tyron smith with back issues and i just
i don't i don't know that
elliot is good enough
to be dominant without the offensive
line we're gonna find out so i don't
know that that may be the comeback i
guess what i'm saying in a nice way is i
think you made a bad pick
here's a pick that you know i could go
one of two ways i could go with the
quarterback whose team used to be in
baltimore or the quarterback of the team
that's currently in baltimore
and i have more faith in joe flacco than
ever i know interlux coming back from
the injury in the last season but what's
what's worse to have not played at all
and have an excuse for not performing or
to have been on the field and just been
horrible which joe flacco was right i
think he is motivated i think he's upset
i think he is determined i think it's
all the ingredients necessary to cause
this guy to come back not to mention
receivers who can get it done too that
was one of the problems in the past few
years right but i think joe flacco is a
guy that we're going to be saying when
we get down the stretch into december
and you start thinking about comeback
player of the year
maybe joe flacco is a guy that we're
going to start thinking about as
comeback player of the year based upon
what i think he can do in 2018 with that
fire under his butt and with some better
options in the past it's amazing what a
little competition will do i mean it's i
used to hate when john gruden used to
bring in four quarterbacks in the
offseason i think damn i mean we got
brian greasy jason garrett brad johnson
and you know luke mccown and but it was
the competition that raised all of our
games and i think that's what you're
seeing from joe flacco you know it's too
many times we let these starters in the
nfl just have these you know cupcake uh
or just these easy way of life as the
starting quarterback with no threat
behind them and i think you do need that
guy there from time to time to drive you
on a daily basis to go oh you know
there's somebody there kind of you know
inching towards me and i need to stay on
my a-game you ever go old school with
any of your competition and spray
shaving cream in their cleats like you
did with jeff hostel
i never did no you know when you wish
you had that tell me where you're
reacting i wish i thought i should have
got some people worse than i did back in
the days but you know when you're in the
moment it's easier to be competitive you
worry about yourself as when you're the
guy that's viewing from the outside
where you have no control that was
tougher to deal with
all right well uh stat staticus that's
who wins it's very close chris you had
aaron rodgers desean watson j.j watt and
ezekiel elliott mike odell beckham jr
david johnson the seahawks and joe
flacco mike started off strong but his
last two picks were very weak especially
the joe flacco because what is he coming
back to mike at his best in the regular
season we've seen him be a slightly
better than average quarterback chris
sims congratulations
you know stats we had a conversation
yesterday about whether or not we should
get a new judge i think we need to
continue that conversation over
breakfast
we won't be eating pancakes sorry
all right i don't care what you eat for
breakfast
you're great stats i love you yeah yeah
see he's the one who brought it up
yesterday we need somebody other than
stats to judge he doesn't know what he's
talking about not now you agree i do yes
he woke up on monday and smarter all
right we'll come back and wrap up this
monday edition of pft library after this
[Music]
you